so
the second generation of the panamera
has been hitting the headlines as
porsche's first plug-in hybrid
which can be charged using a household
electrical socket
the panamera sc hybrid's battery stores
five times as much power as its
predecessor
and at 70 kilowatts its electric motor
is more than twice as powerful
our reviewer says the panamera e hybrid
is quiet as a mouse
all you hear is the tires rolling and
the wind blowing the car has a range of
36 kilometers in pure electric mode
though if driven prudently it can travel
more than 50.
feinholt says that's a quantum leap
compared to its predecessor which
manages two kilometers in electric mode
even when the battery is run down the
panamera doesn't have to be plugged into
a socket
pressing the e charge button turns the
electric motor into a generator
then the gasoline engine drives not only
the wheels its energy is also used to
produce electricity
long drives on the highway can charge
the battery for short emissions-free
jaunts around the city
feinhold is impressed by the way the
e-hybrid switches almost
imperceptibly between gas and electric
mode
the boost function packs the 95
horsepower of the electric motor
onto that of the combustion engine this
makes for 416 horsepower all together
allowing the car to rocket from zero to
100 kilometers an hour
and 5.5 seconds and hit a top speed of
270.
the new hybrid model delivers 306
kilowatts of power
and generates a hefty 590 newton meters
of torque
but thanks to the added electric motor
fuel consumption is just 3.1 liters per
100 kilometers
in electric mode the se hybrid can reach
135 kilometers an hour
not everyone likes the panamera's design
but those who do
like it a lot the rest tend to opt for a
classic 911.
under the hood is a 3 liter v6 engine
that works in tandem with the electric
motor
striking lettering and the porsche
emblem on the wheels
round off the exterior
the battery can be recharged at home
thanks to some special equipment
in germany regular household electrical
sockets have between 8 and 10 amps of
current
explains porsche's robot so it takes
around four hours to charge
the battery fully but if you have access
to high voltage current
you can use that too then a full charge
takes two to three hours
the back end of the e-hybrid is also a
sight to behold
and features led tail lights the trunk
can be opened by pressing a button on
the rear windshield wiper
it offers 335 liters of cargo space
or 1153 liters with the rear seat bench
down
like the panamera gts the se hybrid
uses porsche's active suspension
management system or pasm
it continuously regulates the damping
force for each wheel according to the
road conditions
inside the hybrid looks just like the
regular panamera
say for one tiny detail
the writing on the rev counter
the s e hybrid is fitted with an eight
gear tiptronic s
automatic transmission the leather seats
are comfortable and ooze quality
workmanship
the ultimate in luxury
clearly the se hybrid portion isn't an
eco-friendly car for the masses
its high price tag means it's out of
reach for most
the sedan can be had for 110 000 euros
in germany
but only if you resist the many tempting
optional extras
the smallest member of the alfa romeo
family has had a little surgery
the mito has a new grill that makes the
front of the super mini more streamlined
it's available with five different
gasoline engines and two diesel units
producing between 51 and 125 kilowatts
there's also the mito impression edition
with a new equipment package
prices for the entry level model start
at 14
100 euros
the latest technologies were on show at
the 11th bleh
expo metal work trade fair last week
with a thousand manufacturers gathering
in stuttgart
among the star exhibits were hybrid
materials made from steel
and synthetics that are pushing
lightweight construction forward
and making cars more efficient dual
phase steel is setting new standards for
client seat and strength and opening up
new possibilities for
on-road safety and security
the new volkswagen cross caddy cuts an
imposing figure
in the metallic green tint
the black under right protection and
body panels give the vehicle a robust
appearance
and a hint of adventure
our testament says the caddy and the
cross caddy are both utility vehicles
but many young families opt to buy one
because they're incredibly practical
with rear sliding doors and immense
storage space
mata says if you ignore the plastic on
the dashboard
which looks like a typical utility
vehicle the cross caddy runs like
any premium passenger car
we're testing the cross caddy with a two
liter diesel engine
and four wheel drive in germany the
basic model of this version
costs at least thirty three thousand
five hundred euros
extras can take that up to over forty
thousand
our cross caddy has a hill start assist
function
says the cross caddy has an advantage
over the other volkswagen cross models
because it doesn't just look like an
off-roader it has four-wheel drive too
that means it's fit for all kinds of use
whether by workmen
or families
as is typical for a caddy the trunk is
huge
and it has the usual high ride height
that ground clearance means the cross
caddy has an easy ride
even on unpaved roads but it's also a
benefit on paved once
as it gives the driver a better overview
and traffic
the cockpit is clear and functional like
on other vw models
the green exterior spills over to the
inside
although buyers have a choice between
green and gray
we think this combination has more kick
to it
there are more storage spaces all over
the car too
the caddy was designed as a utility
vehicle but became popular among
families
now volkswagen is taking aim at that
market
so does the cross give buyers something
extra
says that at 40 000 euros the cross
caddy we're driving isn't cheap
but for that you get a vehicle with
loads of room that's well made
and will hold its value
kemia is a beautiful seaside resort in
southwest turkey normally a place to
relax and rejuvenate
for one weekend a year however that
peace and calm is disrupted when the
world's best off-road riders gather here
for the sea to sky event
they start from sea level literally by
the sea before scaling
mount olympus at an altitude of 2365
meters
it's always a good atmosphere you know
like the tourists come they've probably
never seen anything like this so there's
a few heads turning
looking what we're doing so it's
introducing people to the sport as well
and something they've never seen
the writers start day one on the beach
but hardly as bums
this opening stage of the race is all
about speed
thrills spills and spectacular jumps
21 year old johnny walker leaves his
rivals in the dust during qualifying
grabbing pole position for the next
stage
i'm i'm feeling good but it's like every
other race i've been to this year i've
been feeling good but
like herzberg i drowned my bike in the
first water puddle and then
romania because i ran out of fuel so
hopefully nothing goes wrong with this
one
then the battle against the elements
commences from the beach
they head for the forest as the mountain
begins to loom larger
the terrain only gets tougher from here
onwards and the riders will have to use
all their skills to prevail
smooth and swift sections are followed
by tricky technical parts
pushing man and machine to their limits
it's the kind of conditions that
two-time winner graham jarvis revels in
and he makes up ground on fellow
englishman walker
so if a win this year it'll be three
wins on the trot
so would be a nice i'm still hungry as
ever
still really want that win as the race
progresses it becomes increasingly a
quest for climbers
rather than cruisers on this kind of
terrain
experience and technical riding skills
are decisive
not horsepower even the best of them
struggle to overcome
seemingly impassable obstacles wielding
those heavy
100 kilo bikes around corner after
corner
is visibly taking its toll that's an
immense
physical exertion and not just because
of the terrain
the hardest part of this race i think
it's the heat we have
30 more than 30 degrees and yeah
that's the hardest part for me and also
in the
up at the mountain i heard about the
dark canyon
the dark canyon is the final grueling
stage of the sea to sky
only the clem de la creme make it this
far
the exhausted riders have to summon up
whatever strength
they have left to conquer the summit
it's been a neck and neck race between
walker and jarvis
and there's just a few meters separating
them as the finish line comes into view
walker wins ending his streak of bad
luck
the 10 second winning margin was one of
the closest ever an extreme enduro
i think the hardest part for me was
probably coming up towards the end when
uh
when i seen jarvis was catching me i
knew he was coming all all day so
i just i just had to push and then the
last four miles maybe we were both
going backwards and forwards in
positions and eventually got 10 seconds
on him at the top and
that's all that split on his road really
well so
big congratulations to him in third
no small achievement here is an
exhausted alfredo gomez from spain
for dougie lampkin it seemed the torment
would never end
basically i could see the i could see
the red bull arch here
and i thought it was getting close but i
knew the bike was just coming to a stop
and then it looked like it was on fire
there was blue smoke coming from under
the tank and
unfortunately somebody was throwing
water on it just on that corner and then
the bike just stopped then
and i knew there was no chance trying to
restart it i knew that was the end
and one of the photographers put his
cameras down and said let's push it and
i thought
luckily i got some more friends to come
down and give us a hand and
johnny came down now you know after
winning the race came down and got me
through to the end
extreme enduro is the ultimate in
off-road biking
but there's also a lot of camaraderie
between competitors
only the three guys on the podium get
trophies but
every rider who finishes the race is
surely a winner
santa gadda bolognese italy one of those
villages where time seems to have stood
still
everyone knows everyone and everyone
knows lamborghini
this beauty goes by the name job a
survivor of the company's era in
receivership in the early 1980s
and itself marking the end of a
different kind of era
the jaapa was the last lamborghini to be
powered by a v8 engine
the jolpa's roof can be swiftly stowed
away behind the seats
it was lamborghini's answer to ferrari's
popular 308 gts
the company museum on the via modina
houses a choice selection of the luxury
marquis models
lamborghini the name alone is music to
the ears of sports car fans
it took founder ferruccio lamborghini
little over a decade to make his marquee
legend thanks to the 400 gt
the mura and the futuristic [ __ ] touch
1970 had marked the unveiling of the
araco with an all-new clean sheet design
and an eight-cylinder overhead cam
engine the araco
didn't actually hit the market until
1973 however
787 of the first version were built
during its production run through the
end of the decade
its successor the lamborghini silhouette
came in a very limited edition
just 52.
the series culminated in the job 420 of
them were produced from 1982 to 88
lamborghini's last v8 sports car
the 255 horsepower propelled the java
from zero to 100 kilometers per hour in
6.9 seconds
reaching a maximum speed of 240 one of
the fastest cars around
in the early 1980s
but who cares about the bear stats when
you can indulge in the growl of the
8 cylinder beast under the bonnet
the classic toggle switches were not to
be found in the job
the driver monitors engine performance
and speed on dials arranged
in a practical square cube by 1982
standards air conditioning and fine
leather upholstery
made the interior practically palatial
the chaplain may not be a classical
beauty but its design is
uncompromising and shamelessly italian
the exterior boosts flared fenders
and a wedge-shaped body
the mirror proportions of the car
suggest where the v8 is located
behind the driver experienced drivers
will also feel the rear mid engine in
the car's handling
this car is far more agile than the
jalpa's competitors
testing the car's limits is best left up
to the experts
the rear mid engine can be a tricky
monster to master
in 1982 you could get a jopla for about
the same price as a porsche 911
convertible
and a vw golf gti together
today ajapa in sound condition still has
a price tag of some 50 000 euros
the jumper was the last of the
lamborghini v8s
and is for many people the
quintessential italian sports car
of the 1980s
you